So who's my guest this week?
It's the Chief Medical
Advisor to the U.S. President,
Dr. Anthony Fauci.
From death threats to Fauci fever.
If you become one of the biggest figures
of the coronavirus pandemic,
you're going to elicit a reaction.
As a member of the White
House COVID Task Force
under President Trump,
Dr. Fauci became the face
of the U.S. scientific response.
As the crisis continued,
science and politics clashed.
His attempts to understand the virus
and save lives were welcomed by many,
but derided as authoritarian by others.
Some of his advice led
to chants of fire Fauci,
a slogan that was retweeted by his boss
in the Oval Office, but he kept his job.
He says letting the science speak
got him into a little bit of trouble.
So how does he see things now
as the wave of the pandemic retreats
and with a new president
in the White House?
Here's what's coming up.
I chose this and I accept
the risks, but my family,
my wife and my children
continually get hassled
and threatened by things
that are really unimaginable.
Are you relieved you
don't have President Trump
in that position anymore?
Back then it made it
very uncomfortable for me
because I had to frankly disagree publicly
with the president of the United States.
Dr. Fauci, thank you
so much for joining me.
And I have to say, I feel like I know you
because I have seen your face so much
even here in the UK over
the last couple of years.
How has it been for you becoming so much
of a household name?
Well, I don't really think of it at all
as being a household name,
more so that we have to get
the correct evolving,
scientific information out.
And that, since it's such a moving target,
that really necessitates, you know,
rather frequent updating
of what the status is,
both from a public health
as well as from a scientific standpoint.
So it's really a very unique situation
that I and some of my colleagues
find ourselves in,
is that it's not static.
And when you have an event that occurs
and you brief either
domestically or internationally
and generally things don't change,
you don't see very much of a person,
but when you have a very
fluid dynamic situation
that we have right now,
that really creates an
unprecedented situation
where I have become very well-known
merely because of the
need to continually update
and brief at both a domestic
and international level.
I mean, to that point and
I totally take that point
because of the nature of the situation.
I imagine at times it's been frightening,
you know, how much it's been changing
and the reality on people's lives.
You know, you must have
felt enormous pressure.
And I imagine you're also receiving
a lot of emails from people.
A lot of people asking
you what was going on.
Are you able to look back at that now
and kind of take that in?
No, I still can't take it in
because it's completely
transformed my life
in so many ways and, you know,
positive ways and negative ways
because of the charged nature
and the stress that this outbreak has put
on my own country and
throughout the world,
superimposed upon the
divisive political nature
in my own country.
There has been really a
great deal of divisiveness
and even rancor among people
so that you have people who look to you.
Many, many people and I think the majority
that look to the science look to me
as someone who is
communicating the science
and the public health
in a way that's positive
and productive cause they wanna know
what's best for themselves
and their family
and their community.
And yet there are some, you
know, who really are swept up
in conspiracy theories
and distortions of reality
and anti-science untruths
that create a hostility
towards me and the scientific
community in general
that really as unprecedented,
we've never seen anything like that
where the only thing
that I've ever expressed,
everything that I've ever communicated
has been based on the reality
and the evidence as we know it.
And it does change the evidence
because there are things that we know now,
we're dealing with a virus
that continues to fool us.
It continues to move.
It continues to evolve.
It continues to create new variants.
In your country, what do
you attribute that to,
that lack of trust amongst some?
Well, it's become the politicization
of what should be a purely
public health issue.
The idea that we have in our country,
the level of acceptance
of well-proven public health interventions
such as vaccines,
which have clearly been
shown to be lifesaving,
to be highly effective and very safe,
and very often, it's along ideologic lines
when it should be.
There should be no ideological differences
in interpretation of what our core,
immutable public health principles.
And yet the pushback that we have
against seemingly obvious
and scientifically proven
public health principles
is extraordinary.
And the degree of rancor
is such that I never would've imagined
in my wildest dreams that
anything that I've ever said
which is purely public health
and non-political and non-ideologic
leads to continual
death threats against me
to the point where I have to be surrounded
by federal agents for my
protection all the time.
I mean, that seems inconceivable.
If you turn back the clock
and talk about other public health crises
that we've had with polio and with measles
and with smallpox and
the things that we've had
to alert the public to,
there's never been a situation
where the divisiveness have led
to the threat of physical harm.
That is as unprecedented as the notoriety
that I have regarding
the purely communication
of public health principles.
How did you cope with that?
How have you coped with
having death threats?
I mean, are you scared?
What about your family as well?
Well, you know, I mean, I have a job
and I've devoted myself to my job.
I've been at the NIH now
for more than 50 years
and I've been the
director of the Institute,
the National Institute of Allergy
and Infectious Diseases for 38 years
and I've served and
advised seven presidents,
going all the way back to Ronald Reagan.
So this is my job.
I understand it.
And this is the life that I've chosen.
I never would've imagined
that it would be beset
with the kinds of rancor and threats.
So I don't like it.
My family, I think, is the one
that I feel more concerned about because
I chose this
and I accept the risks, but my family,
my wife and my children
continually get hassled
and threatened by things
that are really unimaginable.
I mean, obscene phone calls and threats
and knowing their addresses
and knowing where they work
and knowing what they do and
to continually hassling them.
That is just absolutely preposterous
that that goes on in societies.
I'm very sorry to hear that.
You know, I really am because, of course,
what you're doing at
the same time, you know,
you're trying to save lives
and yet you're receiving death threats.
I understand it's different
to what has been before,
but who do you blame for that?
You know, I don't think
that one can just pick out a person
or a movement to blame,
but what we do have
is something that's very
disturbing in this country,
is what I refer to as the
normalization of untruths.
There's so much distortion of reality
and conspiracy theories
that are spread widely
by social media, where you know,
social media can have a
positive impact on society
by spreading important
productive information.
But when you get total
untruths and quite frankly,
lies and absolute crazy
distortions of reality
that get picked up, spread
through the social media,
and then certain elements
in our own political system
utilize that to distort reality.
And it just compounds the
divisiveness in the country.
When you talk about elements
in the political society,
obviously I was looking back at your time
and what was said certainly
under the previous
president, President Trump,
and reminding myself of the time
he suggested injecting disinfectant
to clean COVID out of the body.
Are you relieved you
don't have President Trump
in that position anymore?
Back then it made it
very uncomfortable for me
because in order to
maintain my own integrity
as well as to fulfill my responsibility
to the American public,
I had to frankly disagree publicly
with the president of the United States.
And that is a very difficult thing to do.
I did not enjoy that,
but that created a backlash against me
by people who were staunchly
loyal to the president.
Can I ask about the America,
whether it's, the U.S.,
whether it's out of the
pandemic phase of COVID,
where are you at with that?
Well, you know, I think
that leads to confusion
because understandably
you would not expect
the general public to appreciate
all the different nuances.
If you talk about the
explosive phase of a pandemic
where you have no countermeasures,
you have no vaccines, you have no drugs.
I mean, thankfully, the number of deaths
and hospitalizations as a ratio
compared to the number
of cases is much lower.
We're having considerable
number of cases now
in the U.S. as we get new and new,
more variants as they evolve.
The deaths are still at
a high level, 300 a day,
but it's not the 3,000 a day
that we were having several months ago.
So, you know, everything is relative.
Are we still in a pandemic?
Absolutely, we are.
Are we in that very fulminant stage
that we were in last year?
No, and hopefully, the more people
that get vaccinated and boosted
and the more people who
realize the importance
of when you have a high
level of viral dynamics,
that when you're in an indoor setting,
you should wear a mask,
even though the whole world
including the United States and the UK
are just worn out and
tired by this outbreak.
It isn't over yet.
People need to realize it is
never gonna go back to zero.
That's not the nature of this virus.
What do you make of those
who talk about the fact
that now the media aren't
doing those daily counts
and it isn't being covered, if you like,
in the same way that, you know,
it was never as bad as it seemed,
if you see what you mean.
So that's not talking about people
who are conspiracy theorists.
I'm talking about those
who say it was hyped
and being hyped and fear was being stoked
by having that level of coverage.
Well, first of all, to say it was hyped
is just completely contradicted
by the terrible burden
that the entire world,
including the UK and
certainly the United States,
we have over 1 million deaths
in the United States from this outbreak.
That's not hype.
That's very painful, stark reality.
So anybody says that
this has been hyped up
is just not looking at
what's going on in the world
and certainly not in the United States.
And the other part of this, part of COVID
is long COVID as well.
People living with the effects of it.
And I wonder, Dr. Fauci,
what was your take on that?
How you would actually define it
'cause there's debates going on
about how it should be
treated as a physical issue,
a psychological issue, as both.
What would you say?
Well, certainly, it's a real phenomenon.
I mean, there's always
psychological stress
associated with disease,
but I think if you put
that aside for a moment,
the idea that there's a certain percentage
of people and it really varies, you know,
from a few percent, 5%
up to 20 or more percent,
of individuals who when they get COVID
and apparently recover
from the acute phase of it
and they are no longer viral positive,
if you wanna use that terminology,
that they have the lingering of symptoms
that are not fully explainable
by any yet identifiable
pathogenic process.
We're working very hard to
try and figure out what it is,
but the symptom complex has
some degree of consistency.
The most dominating
one is profound fatigue
upon minimal exertion.
Something that would
not fatigue you at all
in your prior pre-COVID condition.
People are totally exhausted.
Sometimes, they have very strange things
like sleep disturbances,
like the dysregulation
of body temperatures.
And some of them have a very strange
unexplainable difficulty in
focusing or concentrating,
which is referred to as brain fog.
Well, it sounds hellish.
It sounds awful.
Oh, it is.
It is and it's real.
And that's one of the reasons
why we are concerned about that
and why we're investigating
it so intensively.
So long COVID is something
we need to take seriously
until we find out exactly what it is.
And quite frankly, you have to
be perfectly honest to admit
it is unclear exactly what the mechanism
of this particular condition is.
If I may just take you to another area
of concern at the moment, while
I have some time with you,
there is a lot of concern about monkeypox.
And I wonder what your level of worry
about that is with regards to America
or what you can say about the
current thinking on monkeypox.
Well, I mean, obviously in a world,
a global community that's
been beset with COVID
for two and a half years
and you have yet, again,
another disease that is
now afflicting people,
you've gotta make sure that
A, you don't underplay it
and just brush it aside nor create panic.
There are some significant
differences here
because we've known about monkeypox
for a very long period of time.
It's been endemic in certain countries,
particularly in Central and
West Africa for some time.
By introducing it into
the human population
in non-endemic areas and it looks like,
at least from an
epidemiological standpoint,
that there's a heavy predominance
among the gay community, gay men,
men who have sex with men
because of the close personal
contact that one has.
It's not necessarily in the true sense
and we don't know that,
but it's not necessarily
in the true sense sexually transmitted
but it appears to be transmitted
among sexual partners
in the gay men who have
sex with men population.
I mean, the UNAIDS agency
said at the end of May
that monkeypox, regarding monkeypox,
racist and homophobic rhetoric
risks stigmatizing the disease
and undermining the response.
Dr. Fauci, of course,
you built your career
during the AIDS crisis.
You'll be very familiar with
the risk around stigmatization.
And of course, lessons being
learned from COVID, we hope.
What is your concern or response to that?
Well, I absolutely believe
we've gotta put aside stigma.
There should be no
stigmatization associated
with any subgroup of a
population that has a disease.
So we've gotta strike the delicate balance
of making sure the people who we see
with the evidence appear to be those.
If you look at a group of 2015 people,
the majority of them at
least in the United States
are men who have sex with men.
That should not be a stigmatization,
but that should be a clue to help us
to figure out what's going on right now.
So we've gotta balance
doing the right thing
to alert the appropriate
populations and subgroups,
at the same time as we
don't stigmatize them
because stigma is the enemy of
good public health practices.
We've gotta stay away from that
and do what's right for people
who are at risk for this infection.
I suppose it's just, again,
in the era of social media
and how people like yourself,
public officials like you
can try and get through when we talked
about that atmosphere that
that information lives in now.
Yeah, I mean, social media, again,
is something that, as
I've said so many times
in in other settings, there's
a good positive aspect of it
that you can get good
information circulated
rapidly and widely, but
it is also a great danger
when you get things that are put
into the social media sphere
and you wind up spreading not only stigma
and prejudice, but also
counterproductive information.
So we've gotta be very careful.
Would you say social media companies
having allowed that to
happen in certain instances
pose a public health issue?
You know, I get asked that question often.
I am not very well-tuned into what can
and cannot be done in
regulating disinformation
and misinformation.
That's not my lane.
And I've learned now after
many years of experience,
don't make proclamations in areas
that are not my area of expertise.
So I'm not sure what the
best way to control that.
There is one productive way to do it,
is to try and counter misinformation
and disinformation by getting out there
and proactively putting out correct,
scientifically-based, and
sound correct information.
Well, I mean, I'm also just
minded to bring up the fact
that you've called gun violence in America
a public health issue.
Of course, the debate
about that rages both off
and online as well.
And I wonder, is that cutting through?
Do you think it is finally cutting through
in any way in America?
Can you see the political
divide closing any time soon?
The political divide closing?
No, I see as we approach
a very important election
in the United States
that the political divide
is gonna get even more intense.
You know, one would hope and
I do hope as a physician,
a scientist, and a public health official,
that when you're facing a common enemy,
that that's the time for a
country to pull together.
You know, the way you pull together
after the anthrax attack on our country.
The way you pull together
after a natural disaster.
The way the UK pulled
together during World War II.
And the way we ourselves pulled
together during conflicts.
But unfortunately, we're not seeing that.
We're seeing just the opposite.
We're seeing what should be something
that brings a nation together,
is something that's
actually, unfortunately
and paradoxically having
the opposite effect
of splitting us up even more.
The other disease as it were,
was Fauci fever, I'm told,
that swept the country.
Well, your face has been,
I've been told also,
on things like donuts, all sorts.
What's the weirdest thing
you've seen your face on?
And have you been bought
any of the merchandise?
No, I have not.
I've been given some of the merchandise.
I certainly have not bought it.
Well, have you got a mug, T-shirt?
Well, you know, these
candles that come out
are kind of the more extraordinary.
I mean, I can't imagine I
have my face on a candle.
That's really way out there.
That's way out.
And Brad Pitt apparently played you
on "Saturday Night Live".
Yeah, I know.
You know, most people don't
really appreciate that.
I can't really pay attention to that
because I cannot be distracted
No, I know, I know.
from what I do
on a daily basis.
But if you had to pick
someone to play you,
that's a pretty good one, right?
Well, you know, I said that offhand,
jokingly.
I didn't even know
you said that.
when a reporter asked me,
he said, would you like
to have Ben Stiller
or Brad Pitt play you?
And of course I said, Brad Pitt, you know.
Everybody who's a male wishes
they looked like Brad Pitt,
which I certainly don't.
Well, Dr. Fauci, we watched it
so you didn't have to, you know?
You were too busy trying to
get that information across.
Thank you very much for
sparing the time today.
It's been good to talk to you.
My pleasure, good to be with you.
Thank you for having me.
Thank you.
And thank you for being with us, too.
Until we meet again,
take care and goodbye.